welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and venom let there be carnage as a
new trailer that lets there be plenty of
carnage carnage
with venom do an impression of us
whenever sony releases a no way home
trailer oh [ __ ]
that's just a rainy one get vaccinated
and we can revert coming this fall to
come in this september and save
christmas by keeping no way home on
schedule two
sure i'll drink that kool-aid oh yeah
i'm gonna break down this trailer frame
by frame for all the hidden details that
you might have missed including the ways
this film will fuse or
to fuse to sony's other spider-man
titles this video is brought to you by
oneplus and their nord line of phones
they have a wild new launch video that
you're gonna have to see to believe
and i'm gonna be reacting to it later in
this video we opened with eddie on his
ducati
he did have a motorcycle in the first
movie but not a ducati and notice how
venom controls his hands as he drives
similar to how eddie let venom jesus
take the wheel in his previous chase
now eddie's helmet is a matching red
with a black visor and his motorcycle
jacket is black with blue stripes and
one red stripe all of which could be
part of a color scheme to reflect his
relationship with cletus cassidy and
carnage
venom in the comics is black with a blue
outline often and carnage is of course
red with a black outline and this movie
revises carnage's origin
story from eddie's symbiote producing an
offspring that fuses with the cellmate
cletus cassidy to instead now be the
result of cletus biting eddie
and getting eddie's symbiote-infused
blood in his system
i have tasted blood before and that
is not it that's mine it's yours
and what's yours is mine
and maybe this color design is that you
got your chocolate my peanut butter you
got your peanut butter my chocolate idea
with carnage's early form still having
that black
in his face before he appears to go all
red
later on almost like he begins similar
to the 1999 mummy who still must feast
to reach his final complete form
meanwhile after the bite
those bits of red and eddie's costuming
are reflecting the way cassidy has left
him with some internal psychological
bleeding venom chews on this tire chew
toy marks snooki
not spelled like nicole please he spells
it but likes snooky's cookies also looks
like a tire that might have been used as
a buoy on the side of a boat that might
have been named snooki eddie warns venom
that they'll be dragged off to area 51
and interesting of eddie to mention area
51 existing in this universe because
area 51 was the subject of a blog post
on j jonah jameson's daily bugle website
that was released by sony now as we
still wait for a trailer for spiderman
no way home and speculate on the ways
loki and sylvie busted up the mcu's
sacred timeline into a multiverse we
gotta admit jk simmons showing up as j
jonah jameson in far from home with no
explanation could be
one way alternate universe crossovers
could have already been happening in the
mcu
and thus could signal sony and marvel's
plans to
justify how these crossovers are
happening that's not to say venom
literary carnage will be in the mcu no i
don't think that's gonna be the case but
with a title like spider-man no way home
i think sony might try to hint that it
could be kind of this nexus point where
on one side of a multiversal portal
could be
other sony universes like the raimi
verse like the mark webb universe and
like this venom corner of the universe
we visit the ravencroft institute a
prison in lab where super criminals are
experimented on in the marvel comics
an east coast version of this showed up
in the amazing spider-man 2 where
elektro was briefly kept we see this
woman with silver hair walking down the
hallway
she actually later appears outside of
shriek's cell closing the hatch that's
presumably to
prevent shriek sonic blasts from getting
out this woman also showed up outside
the chamber in the last trailer this
could be dr kafka who runs the
ravencroft institute in the comics now
shriek is frances barrison who teams up
with carnage in the maximum carnage
comic that seems to be partly inspiring
this movie's plot she has the ability to
emit these powerful sonic blasts
and considering such frequencies tend to
destabilize symbiotes from their hosts i
assume she will end up being the crucial
weapon against venom or carnage or both
notice how she has one
blue eye a nod to the blue mark that is
over her eye in the comics here look
closely she is reading the daily bugle
and the headline i think reads cletus
cassidy dead
maybe cletus and francis had a previous
relationship
and when cassidy escaped he could have
been falsely reported as dead with
guards and media either not
understanding what that carnage
transformation was or
technically this transformation occurred
after he flatlined in the execution room
and when i do a breakdown of this movie
that will be the point i pitch a
bat-shit theory that the whole movie
takes place
in cletus cassidy's flickering fantasies
in the moments of his death venom breaks
eddie's nose
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it
again you are a loser and you can see
how eddie's crooked nose straightens
itself from the inside
similar to the way venom straightened
eddie's broken limbs in the first movie
then this crime scene where eddie is
being
interviewed by media now eddie's
interviews with clevis cassidy seem to
have led to discovery of
bodies of cletus cassidy's past victims
making the police look bad and making
eddie more of a star for the daily bugle
and we see eddie working on that story
on his laptop
daily bugle west coast edition since of
course it is based out of new york
inside the mind of serial killer cletus
cassidy we get inside the mind of cletus
cassidy the famous serial killer of our
country
in this exclusive report that delves
into his dark past investigating his
motives and madness
the masthead and logo are the same as
the design we saw in the sam rainey
spider-man movies
unlike the infowars design of the
website in the mcu now of course the
raimi verse already had a venom and the
andrew garfield mark webb had a daily
bugle and a j jonah jameson who appeared
only in angry
emails in peter parker's inbox on the
left side of the screen you can see that
eddie has an actual account with the
daily deagle server
meaning that he is working for them full
time now among his notes are some of
cletus cassidy's drawings with a tree
and a church similar to the sketches he
made on the walls of his prison cell and
on the tree is the quote
to thee the strife was given between the
suffering
this is a line from prometheus an 1816
poem by english poet
lord byron which is a celebration of the
titan from greek mythology who
stole fire from the gods to benefit
mankind it romanticizes his defiant
struggle against the gods wrath as he
brought
mortals and immortals closer in status
similarly with a title like let there be
carnage a paraphrase from the book of
genesis
cassidy sees himself as a god figure
seeking to immortalize himself by
stealing a power that came from the
heavens similarly on his prison cell
wall is a quote from mary shelley's
frankenstein
title also known as the modern
prometheus which was written
in the same english romantic literary
era in 1818
exploring a similar subject matter of
mankind defying mortality and producing
this suffering lonely promethean figure
now oneplus and their nord line have
made a name for themselves as the
affordable giant killers of the
smartphone world they just launched
their latest and most important product
the nord 2
phone with an insane launch film called
nord of the ring
and of course thanks to oneplus nord for
sponsoring this video
oneplus nord is an affordable smartphone
fully equipped with the features one
would expect from its more expensive
competitors they're known for their
unique product launches like last year
when they did the world's first ar
launch for the nord one they topped
themselves this year with a hollywood
action movie quality launch film it has
a huge
cast epic locations and ridiculous
special effects that give the nord 2 an
mcu worthy origin story let's check it
out
whoa the devices were then trained oh my
gosh god yes i love that a mad scientist
gave the phone an advanced charger
and that's a solid mad scientist laugh
by the way
oh my god the scientists tried
desperately to hide from their captors
make them understand that they had no
idea what they were doing
oh my god you don't know what you're
doing
but the bad guys hated science
science
oh my god oh my god it's very exciting
what is this
did he just shoot that scientist in the
head and not expect that from a
smartphone launch video
i also noticed some homages to raiders
of the lost dark john wick and
germanotoro
energy and a bunch of other different
genre elements there it's a fun video
with a great sense of humor to go along
with the cool special effects
go watch this film for yourself on the
nord channel which is linked in this
video's description and check out their
product link down there as well if the
nord 2
is available in your area cassidy says
people love
serial killers correctly observing that
this latest craze of true crime
genre and documentary series and
podcasts society really has this dark
fixation with famous sadistic
psychopaths
cassidy bites eddie on his hand the same
place that peter parker
famously gets bitten to get his powers
though in this case the power transfer
goes to the biter and in the other
trailer cassidy kills a spider
as he writes these postcards to eddie
which looks like he's writing it in his
blood which might be how this
relationship grew prior to the cross
contamination cassidy helps eddie grow
in his journalistic fame so now cassidy
feels like eddie owes him something
carnage stops cassidy's execution you
can see it leaking across his eyeballs
in these red ink stains actually similar
to the bluish blackish ones in eddie's
eyes in the previous film and then
bursting out of his chest and his hands
in these red tendrils and listen closely
to this moment
yeah there's that little squeak at the
end of the roar that you can also hear
later during the prison shootout
[Music]
yeah it doesn't sound like a pained wine
released by a wounded animal but rather
a high-pitched demonic squeal made by
something whose vocal cords are
mid-transformation like a windpipe being
turned inside out and cassidy morphs
into carnage
i love how it first drains his eyeball
to form this
bulbous form of a carnage eyeball all
while tugging
out the side of his mouth that he opens
to release
carnage's thick gross tongue as if this
all tearing out from cassidy's scream he
spends a lot of time in this church
which seems like a nod to the level of
the maximum
carnage game but i believe there also
might be some influences from the more
recent
absolute carnage comic series which
featured carnage taking over a cult
worshipping the symbiote klyntar deity
of null
and puppeting the unfortunate homeless
of san francisco as these drones as he
forms his church of carnage
now the previous trailer showed steven
graham's character detective mulligan
in his office with a map of san
francisco's tenderloin district
known for its high population of
homeless people with a few incident
markings on those blocks by the way it
is believed that mulligan
could be patrick mulligan a cop who in
the comics gets infected with an
offspring of carnage to become the
character toxin carnage helps cassidy
escape prison
you can see as guards are closing in one
of carnage's tendrils in the background
suspend
one dude high in the air these guards
shoot at him and he opens a hole in his
chest to let the bullets sail through
and hit the guards behind him but this
also shows how cassidy isn't like
floating inside carnage wearing him like
a suit but rather
his flesh is fully infused with the
symbiote matter
that's why venom freaks out when carnage
is a red one it signals to him that
cassidy
has fully given over his blood to the
symbiote making them one
a stronger and more lethal connection
than the give and take of eddie in
venom's relationship
carnage pins his prison guard and gives
him a franchie
i can't really tell if he's feeding on
his organs or using the spiky tension of
his tongue to whisk it all up and then
this title card says
this fall a bit worrisome since the
release date is supposed to be september
24th in the us september 15th in the uk
making some of us a bit concerned that
maybe rising cases of the delta variant
might delay the release
no this does not mean spider-man no way
home will get pushed i just think sony
is keeping their options
open for let there be carnage carnage
faces a helicopter with his tendrils
wrapped around it looks like his
convertible there now cassidy appears
sitting next to francis in this car in
the other shot and then there's a third
shot showing francis using her sonic
blast to blow out the windshield at
someone while pieces of carnage are
wrapped around this car i assume this is
all part of their escape from the
ravencroft institute which you can also
see as carnage's arms explode out of the
hatch of francis's cell in another shot
where it tears down that same ravencroft
hallway then a close-up shows a framed
photo of annie with a cat from the first
movie named mr belvedere now the hand
holding that frame has that engagement
ring
making this annie so maybe eddie return
this photo that he had of annie as a way
of signaling that he
is moved on and that he's okay with her
engagement to dan and then this great
moment where venom reacts to carnage
oh
yes it's a bit similar to hulk's refusal
to take the reigns from bruce banner and
infinity war but here yeah venom clearly
fears carnage and cassidy's pure blood
symbiosis compared to his weaker hold on
eddie i love this detail eddie's mumford
phys ed department shirt with his
detroit lions jacket
is an odd to another famous eddie eddie
murphy in beverly hills cop 2. and when
eddie says i'll let you eat
everybody he is referring to multiple
enemies that they're about to face and
if you look closely on the far end of
the church on the altar beside cassidy
there is a dark figure standing beside
him that must be the final form of
shriek
we also get this pretty gnarly close-up
of carnage's head notice the texturing
on his tongue
all these black pock marks like it is
decaying and then the contouring of his
eye socket
it is jagged just like it is in the
comics like someone took their fingers
and dipped it in white paint and just
smeared it on the back of his head then
we see cassidy doing a little victory
dance outside san quentin and then
robbie what looks like mrs chen's store
the cashier could be her son but more
importantly this means cassidy is
in eddie's neighborhood security feed on
the screen nearby shows outside
including that red convertible that he's
been driving around in and then this
montage of the fight between venom and
carnage carnage's appendages pin venom
against the wall of a church putting him
in a christ pose meaning he might try to
execute him via crucifixion in this
church it's a bit appropriate there
eddie and annie meet at that restaurant
that they dined at in the 2018 film and
her engagement ring if you compare that
to the one eddie gave her in the
previous film now that center stone is
surrounded by
a double halo and has stones on the band
it's just a way more expensive
version of the ring that eddie got her
which might be why eddie and venom take
it so personally
you can support new rockstars by
checking out our many great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching
[Music]
you